si usted o alguien que conoce se ha
sometido recientemente a una
intervención de injerto de derivación
coronaria o cavg por sus siglas en
inglés este video le ayudará a entender
los pasos del procedimiento y De qué
manera se restablece el flujo sanguíneo
al corazón el injerto de derivación de
coronaria o cavg se realiza para mejorar
la circulación del miocardio en este
procedimiento se conecta o se injerta
una arteria o vena sana de otra parte
del cuerpo a la arteria coronaria
obstruida la arteria o la vena injertada
elude la parte bloqueada de la arteria
coronaria y lleva sangre rica en oxígeno
al miocardio en una sola operación se
pueden puentear una o varias arterias
coronarias
antes de la intervención se le colocará
una vía intravenosa y es posible que se
le administre un medicamento para
ayudarlo a relajarse los procedimientos
de cavg se realizan con anestesia
general por lo que estará dormido
durante la operación se le insertará un
tubo respiratorio a través de la boca y
en la garganta para ayudarlo a respirar
se le colocará una sonda en la vejiga
para drenar la orina
la intervención de derivación coronaria
suele durar entre 3 y 6 horas durante
una operación de derivación convencional
el cirujano comienza haciendo una
incisión en la piel sobre el esternón
a continuación cortará el esternón y
moverá la caja torácica para llegar al
corazón durante el procedimiento su
sistema circulatorio puede estar
conectado a una bomba de derivación
cardiopulmonar o sistema de circulación
extracorporal esta máquina puede cumplir
temporalmente las funciones del corazón
y de los pulmones durante la operación
lo que permite detener el corazón Si se
desea mientras el cirujano cose los
injertos en su lugar para los injertos
se suelen utilizar diferentes vasos
sanguíneos la arteria torácica interna
del tórax también conocida como arteria
mamaria interna o las venas ajenas de
las piernas
para el injerto con la arteria torácica
interna el cirujano dejará el extremo
superior unido a la arteria subclavia y
desviará el extremo inferior de la pared
torácica a la arteria coronaria justo
después de la obstrucción
a continuación el cirujano cocerá el
injerto en su lugar
para el injerto con la vena safena el
cirujano suturará un extremo a la aorta
y el otro extremo a la arteria
estenosada justo después de la
obstrucción
cuando los injertos estén bien colocados
el cirujano puede utilizar señales
eléctricas para restablecer el ritmo
cardíaco Y colocar un marcapasos
temporal en el corazón una vez que el
corazón vuelve a latir con normalidad si
el cirujano utilizó el sistema de
circulación extra corporal lo
desconectará el cirujano volverá a unir
el esternón y suturará la incisión de la
piel
se colocará un tubo de drenaje temporal
a través de la piel debajo de la
incisión
cuando el cirujano opta por realizar la
operación sin utilizar el sistema de
circulación extra corporal el corazón
sigue latiendo esto puede denominarse
cirugía de derivación sin bomba o
cirugía mínimamente invasiva
en este caso se utiliza un dispositivo
mecánico para estabilizar la parte del
corazón donde se realiza el injerto
los cirujanos realizan procedimientos de
derivación mínimamente invasivos con
instrumentos especialmente diseñados que
se introducen a través de pequeñas
incisiones o vías en el pecho
después de la operación se lo llevará a
la unidad de cuidados intensivos se
controlará con minuciosidad la actividad
de su corazón si es necesario se
utilizarán cables de electroestimulación
para controlar temporalmente su
frecuencia cardíaca el tubo torácico
permanecerá en su lugar para drenar el
exceso de sangre y aire de la cavidad
torácica una vez que pueda respirar por
su cuenta Se le retirará el tubo
respiratorio y se lo sustituirá por una
máscara de oxígeno la Sonda vesical
permanecerá en su lugar a medida que se
recupera de la operación quirúrgica
Durante los próximos tres a cinco días
todos estos dispositivos se retirarán
gradualmente
tras el alta de la intervención
asegúrese de ponerse en contacto con su
médico Si tiene alguna duda o
experimenta algún efecto secundario de
los medicamentos que está tomando